all right let's just start the podcast
Charlie's in a bad mood I'm not in a bad
mood I just uh I'm just like right but
it's funny it's funny that we we put up
a merch store and we're selling buttons
for three dollars and didn't realize
that people were seeing bills for ninety
three dollars that is fun that's funny
too I think it's kind of funny oh yeah
for sure well I think what people need
to understand is if if you don't if you
are a a small like our operation is not
big it's we're outboard starting merch
store right where it's the small thing
right now you know so we don't have a
warehouse in another country what most
places what most companies would do is
they just wouldn't ship you anything at
all you wouldn't even have the choice
at least with us you have the option if
you want to pay ninety dollars where are
the good guys we're just three young
upstarts just and some guys just trying
to start trying to start a small
business right just three good looking
guys and a good looking woman trying to
just try very good looking group of
people just trying to so young we don't
know the rules of Customs no we haven't
learned anything else
and when you're good looking you're you
don't have to know that many things
because you get by just on your looks as
we have and so we're learning these
things now because we realize we're like
we gotta pull ourselves up by our
bootstraps you know what I mean because
these looks aren't going to last forever
you know let's take advantage of while
we're young we'll learn about
International tariff law at some point
in our careers but we're just getting
started okay yes but we'll wait till
we're ugly but we decided not to wait
and now we're paying the price yeah well
we're not paying the price today
somebody else is paying the price
by the way I don't even have a pin
listen pal
that was handed to me as a prop
[Laughter]
um I can get it too but it'll cost 90
for me to drive it to your house
[Laughter]
he's rich
it's a large t-shirt which he wanted I
did thank you for saying that on me on
the podcast podcast yeah the mediums are
a little a little small you're exploding
out of the medium yeah a little bit a
little tight yeah what's going on with
the medium fit have you been I have not
tried uh yeah the medium fit me but I
you you've always had big arms which by
the way God bless God bless you you know
I remember I remember early on like in
the before we started doing the show you
and I used to every once in a while we'd
go work out at the YMCA sure you know
the uh the young men's Christian
Association yeah yeah in West Hollywood
sometimes we play racquetball but
sometimes we'd lift weights and I
remember
I'd be over there doing arms because
I've always had skinny arms I have a
very hard time building my arms and uh
you wouldn't do arms at all because your
whole thing was like
they'll get too big bro
that's because you've got big arms too
he didn't want to make me feel bad I
appreciate that buddy you got it buddy
thanks God I definitely did definitely
rock some arms with you did you and what
what year are we talking about early to
the priests yeah pretty sunny and I
remember uh you it was a it was a
strength in yours you like uh you know
big arms the chest game was standard but
the arm game was exceptional I was like
look at the arm game you also never did
ABS back in the day never did ABS you
you were like yeah
that's what the exactly yeah that's what
the glamor muscle phrase came from too
yeah well yeah but I mean I guess ABS
will be considered glamor muscles the
ABS wood and so would buy buys and tries
but uh yeah I suspect maybe you saw my
body and you were like you know what
I'll do chest with this guy and make him
feel good about himself I always had a
pretty good maybe you just wanted to
have the body that was look good on a
billboard oh yeah that's a good
transition
you guys want to talk about the episode
I want to talk about arms and chests
[Music]
think about this episode this is not an
episode you can see on TV no longer
available that's yeah no longer
available
yeah
um it's a tough thing to talk about
it's a tough thing to talk about but
maybe it's a tough thing to talk about
without getting heavy and then going
into a
defensive stance on but it's almost like
a satire and what it's kind of odd thing
not to address right to be like we're
gonna talk about an episode and the fans
can't watch it at home it's hard for me
to look at that episode and look at Max
Behavior right which is insanely
misogynistic yeah and then to say well
that is appropriate because we're
suggesting that these are terrible
characters and this it's a show that is
taking a satirical look at at our
culture and then say well that's okay to
do but certain things are not
here's my honest feeling about it I
think these things are complex and
I don't think that it does the audience
a service
to
take away their ability to look at a
piece of what we want to call it art or
storytelling or whatever it is from the
past to remove the ability
to let let the audience sort of like uh
break it down for themselves I don't
think it's positive I think go ahead and
put a disclaimer on there and be like
look look
there's some humor in this that
could be offensive so tread lightly but
like I don't know even that so you'd
have to put that in front of every
episode yeah go ahead then fine but
that's what the rating system is tbma
are you are you mature enough to watch
this or are you a child
where are you child yeah yeah right
that's what tvma is or tv14 it's it's to
suggest that if you're an adult you have
the ability to discern what and take
away what you were going to take away
the reason that this is down is because
of the two characters that Caitlyn plays
that D plays
is an important distinction yeah
characters the D place right yes that is
that is an important distinction yeah
like yeah that D is trying to become a
YouTube sensation and she's doing
characters that she thinks would pop on
Saturday Night Live and I specifically
referred to them and certainly the
second one as as racist
um so it's not like the show is not no
the joke aware of it it's look it's
satire that's what it is you know what I
mean you're yeah sweet D is a very
ignorant person that's right and is
unaware of the impact that's what the
joke is supposed to be yes it's
difficult because I can sit here and
defend it you know with that logic right
because it's a person who is you know
doesn't realize how you know ignorant
and racist they're being
um and that is the joke
um you know about the show and that is
the show and speaking of the show from
this episode I'd like to start by
talking about Su and your A's don't wear
a C and J all over your B's so I'll tell
you what s is it's screw screw you okay
right I was thinking sex sex you but
you're probably right don't wear a
condom don't wear a condom screw you and
jizz all over your butts don't worry
yeah
we went for f u in the a but I believe
that was the standards and practices
though yeah you can't say F you in the a
you can't say F U yeah I think I think
you can't have you in the a you can do
racist stereotypes that's right that was
fun at the time yes later dudes ask you
in your A's don't wear a c in jail over
your B's That's a classic Charlie line
that gets quoted a lot yeah yeah uh
that's a pretty great one sure yeah s u
in the a what is it again s u in your in
your A's don't wear a C and J all over
your B's yeah
as a parting line that's pretty 46. yeah
that's funny that could be carved on a
tombstone of somebody I mean that could
just be absolutely so yeah we'll just
yeah that'll be on your Tombstone but
that'd be up to me I'll be dead
you know I'm Ash I'm Ash baby no throw
me in the ocean uh yeah um Danny I think
we first started getting his hair going
uh out in this episode we started
pulling it out a little bit we started
getting a little Wilder and he's got the
bigger glasses in the season which is
right frames yeah um first time we ever
had TJ
yeah playing Rex super funny guy great
doctor and a bodybuilder I'm not sure
what he considers himself primarily
although I feel like I feel like he's I
mean I follow him on Instagram he's
super into bot I feel like he's even
more into bodybuilding now than he was
back then because like I mean he's he's
what you see in this episode times he's
in there
yeah yeah he's bigger he's bigger he's
more vascular he's even more cut the man
if he has any body fat at all
uh I don't know where it went I don't
know where it is
and I and I worry for him because that's
that's you got to have some you gotta
have a little bit kind of a little bit
otherwise you're eating your organs
that's right you get it that's right
yeah that's right he's eating all the
fat and it's like well where else is
there fat this is you know surrounding
my vital organs around the heart I'll
eat those too
um
you you refer to Rex's bird that just
won't quit yeah did you guys like
realize that bird had become a word that
you can't apply to I mean now that
because by this point it's very much
applied to D yeah but you're still using
it is a is a word to describe a a
phallus
um that was uh but I don't from
Philadelphia yeah I was gonna say is
that specifically a Philadelphia thing
because I'd never very specifically the
Northeast part of Philadelphia oh yeah I
don't think I'd heard it before that
episode no and that was was in the
script there's a great there is a uh
there's a funny blooper from that uh
that is a very genuine reaction from me
because you decided in one take instead
of saying bird you just sweated you said
there's a sweaty hog in those pants and
you didn't tell me you were gonna say it
fair enough uh I had no I'd never heard
you use that term before I'd never heard
that term used period And so when you
see me laugh in that that's the first
time that's me hearing that for the
first time that's not me hearing a line
that we wrote and laughing that's me
hearing it for the first time and
breaking I bet you if you pop those
jeans off you're gonna find a sweaty hog
that won't quit either come on come on
you know what's interesting about this
episode so we're watching it and uh you
know we're commenting on reality shows
which are really just starting to hit
their stride right whether it's the Fear
Factor or it's um America's Next Top
Model Top Model or what's the one the
dating The Bachelor we're hitting all
those but we're also kind of hitting
YouTube culture yeah which we're like oh
if you're Chocolate Rain or the woman
who was stomping and falling on the
grapes like
you're getting a bunch of followers on
that and you think that's fame or
whatever I think we're being a little
bit oh yeah we're having a go at people
who want to be become famous just for
being here just for yeah just for being
there from that time till now
like that has become the norm like that
is
mainstream sort of awareness of people
is via what they're doing on the
internet whether it's tick tocker and
I've taken a little bit of a turn on
that like I really used to I'll I'll
admit like kind of stem snub might snub
my nose at like
you know Instagram influencers or or
anything like that but I've kind of
taken a little bit of turn where I'm
like
hey yeah they had a platform people use
their platform and it's empowering that
you don't have to you don't have to go
to one of the studios to fund something
or one of the decision yeah it's it's
incredible it just empowers people to
build whatever they want yeah and I
don't have to I don't have to like what
they're selling or what they're doing I
mean there's there's plenty of that on
TV too there's a lot of people who don't
like our show they don't like what we're
selling either sure so you know what I
mean they're doing the same thing they
just they took the middleman out they
took the studios and the networks out
and they were like
I can reach an audience directly with
what I think is is interesting and
worthy of you know talking about and and
I've realized now that like
that's pretty [ __ ] smart they were
way smarter than I was I didn't figure
that [ __ ] out I didn't see I didn't see
a future in that I just thought like wow
what a really pathetic like way to try
to become famous I'll fully admit that I
was like judgmental about it the then
there were people who sort of used that
tool with their sort of mainstream Fame
and used it really well first guy I
remember kind of like going on a terror
that was Dane Cook who was doing his
stand-up but he was like huge on MySpace
yeah and then you know like the Rock and
Kevin Hart these guys had like just
giant internet followings that that
matched there and now everyone's chasing
it right like everyone's like well I
guess gotta have something but then
there were the people that figured out
like why don't I become famous first
instead of doing something and becoming
famous for that thing that I do let me
just go ahead and become famous first
and then I'll sell products sing a song
yeah yeah sure yeah which which is like
[ __ ] smart yeah I think there's been
a change too because I remember the
earliest days of viral videos it felt
like everyone wasn't it wasn't made to
go viral it was just a clip of a news
show like the woman stomping grapes or
was the Chocolate Rain thing which
wasn't supposed to be seen by millions
of people but then it just like caught
fire but now people are like they they
kind of have cracked the code of oh how
do I make something that will go viral
but I remember there were a lot of years
like working on um TV shows where the
like marketing the execs or whatever
would come in and be like we'd love you
guys to make a viral video and we're
like Yeah well yeah that's it you can't
no it's like put viralness in it you
know not that great right what a virus
in it um that great video uh was one of
the first
the internet YouTube or actually I think
even before YouTube that that was like
making the rounds on like certain like
e-bombs worlds
oh my God good memory that's exactly
where I saw it that and the the guy who
was auditioning for something with
nunchucks and then did a backflip and
landed on his face and got up and tried
to keep going
into the backdrop or whatever yeah like
there were just a handful of those like
things YouTube was like the history of
the dance right like wasn't there oh my
God and that was the first video that
just like broke a million like it was
like huge yeah yeah yeah right bit my
finger Charlie bit my finger was also
like in their mid-30s yeah yeah yeah for
sure but the the grape stomping thing I
mean really all that all those were were
America's Funniest Home Videos yeah
without the [ __ ] uh host yeah you
know it was with and you get to see the
whole thing instead of seeing like a
tiny little clip of it you know and and
somebody like making a stupid comment
about it you get to just watch the thing
raw yeah yeah
that grape one is great by the way we
should put that on the podcast yeah yeah
I love that video is that anymore it's
owned by culture I feel like you can
just I have that now these buckets are
filled with grapes what kind of grapes
these are filled with Chambers and
grapes and the winner this Saturday he's
still music eating International Foods
having wine tours and tastings Vineyard
tours seminars arts and crafts it's a
lot of fun a whole day stop
oh
oh I can't breathe
I wonder where that lady is let's find
out where that lady is oh I'll look it
up I put a little Chiron
she passed and she died from grape
exposure I started laughing at her pain
I mean she fell down and is in part
she's an exceptional pattern
well no you're laughing at the fact that
she tries to cheat right yeah so she
tried doing the thing and then she goes
stop and then and the other woman stops
and then she starts and then she starts
because they're having a race to see who
can like get the most wine from
Strawberry so she falls out of the
bucket [ __ ] cheater [ __ ] cheater
you're laughing at a pain of Justice
but it does I mean she
like you could yeah it's totally off I'm
glad it's off camera because it's very
possible that she lost like quite a few
teeth because I mean she goes down and
it almost seems like she takes forward
enough time to like landed on her face I
know first
um but that but it is also the sound of
someone who got the wind yeah right yeah
so yeah she gave an interview with a
radio program where she said am I
embarrassed that I felt of course I also
broke a couple ribs thanks for asking I
had to spend a few weeks in the hospital
under observation I suffered quite a bit
for an honest mistake a momentary lapse
in concentration and now I'm trying to
move on you [ __ ] [ __ ] that was not
an honest mistake it was a dishonest
mistake [ __ ] [ __ ] wow now hold on a
Sunday we gotta cut this whole option
yes are you kidding me this is great
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
what are your plans for the rest of the
summer I mean we're sort of at the
halfway mark here halfway
we got like a month left
well look regardless of how long we have
left the key to summer is finding as
much free time as possible to enjoy
getaways you know so enjoy some cookouts
time at the pool trying desperately to
keep your house plants alive that's
right and if you're a business owner the
last thing you'll want to do is spend
time sorting through tons of unqualified
candidates resumes and that's hard to do
while running the grill or laying out on
the beach well that's why you need zip
recruiter to find great candidates you
know they do the work for you and now
you can try it for free at
ziprecruiter.com Sunny well ZipRecruiter
uses its powerful technology to find and
match the right candidates to your job
then you can review these recommended
candidates and directly invite your top
choices to apply you guys know the four
out of five employers on ZipRecruiter
get a high quality candidate on the
first day that's actually true that
could be you so soak up all that summer
has to offer and let zip recruiter do
the work ready for the URL are you guys
are you ready it's ziprecruiter.com
sunny that's where you can try it for
free again that's ziprecruiter.com Sunny
s-u-n-n-y zip recruiter the smartest way
to hire
I gotta say I I'm feeling really rested
today I am feeling rested and I have a
hunch as to why
are you gonna tell us what do we have to
guess yeah I want you to guess it's
because of your Helix mattress that's
what it is
yeah yeah yeah they really do make some
standout mattresses I gotta say I've got
their I've got their uh Birch organic
line man let me tell you it's a huge
upgrade over what I used to have Helix
mattresses are also great for spinal
alignment to prevent aches and pains and
they even have Helix Plus for our plus
size kings and queens Kings for our
kings and queens for our Queens they
also have a 10-year warranty and you get
to try them out for a hundred nights
risk-free so they'll even come to your
house and pick them up if you don't love
them but uh let's be real you will love
them you don't want to take our word for
it because we're morons take the words
of GQ and wired magazines who named
Helix the number one best overall
mattress of 2021. in addition to the
word of leading chiropractors and
doctors of sleep medicine and guys right
now Helix is offering up to 200 off all
mattress orders and two free pillows for
our listeners at helixsleep.com Sunny so
get on it get on the order get on the
bed that is Helix sleep.com slash sunny
[Music]
I don't remember e-bounds world I
totally remember eBaum's World it was
like I wonder if does ebab's world still
exist is that still a thing
it wasn't it wasn't really
um when when we started watching it it
wasn't it wasn't um real time streaming
you would have to you'd have to almost
like LimeWire uh where you'd have to
download LimeWire yeah you would you'd
have to like download you can stream it
you couldn't just click on a video and
stream it I think you could yeah but it
was like only like really short clips
and then others you had to like you take
a while to download it yeah but it was
bait what was e-bounds was it always
just a place to to because then College
Humor came along
and became a forum to post like comedic
videos and you know stuff like that Will
Ferrell one no no that was funny or die
right yeah yeah yeah
um I'm not sure who star well actually
uh yeah actually I do know that Ricky
Van Veen who produced Coffee Town the
movie that I did he was one of the
founders of of uh college humor because
that was a college humor movie it's the
only feature movie they ever made
interesting what like what internet
things have endured like Reddit you know
yeah like you you look at like the sort
of platform of Reddit and it seems very
kind of basic
you know in its designed the times but
it's you know
Twitter
I think that that that Reddit works
that was Instagram I guess there's Tick
Tock what do the kids do now yeah baby I
think that's what people like about
Reddit though I mean and again I don't I
don't really know it's one of the things
I like about Reddit is it's just like
it's a
you it's not about like the design of
the page is very very basic but in a way
it's kind of it's great it makes it
easier to look for
you know because it's less about less
about the uh the page itself and more
about what you can find on there what
people are posting and so you just
you're really just scrolling through
posts
uh but I I like Reddit I don't use it
all that often but it's it's pretty it's
pretty fun to just scroll through
Maggie has read it I do I'm on Reddit
yeah and I yeah and I go to the sunny
subreddit all the time and I um engage
see I don't know how to use it like I
don't know it's easy it's just like a
message board like you just hit reply
and then you can type right in but you
have to like have a sign in I guess and
yeah I got into Reddit like a while ago
I guess it was when I was still working
on community and we had like a massive
subreddit on community and
I convinced them to do an AMA ask me
anything and that went like pretty big
so then I don't know I've just but
actually weirdly enough separately
um I took a photo once of my sister's
um now ex-husband's dog
um and uh posing underneath a painting
of itself
um the dog's name was Del Mar and
there's a picture I took of it posing
underneath the painting of itself and uh
posted put that on Twitter and somebody
took it and put it up on Reddit and then
that went viral it got like millions of
hits what yeah to the point where then
as a joke I got my sister a phone case
that had this picture on it and she
would get like stopped by people and
they were like oh I've seen that dog so
that was like my little viral moment I
guess of something when you're when
you're making comments on Reddit do
people know it's you yeah because I have
my username and so um yeah so like when
the shipping thing happened I went on
Reddit and I was like Hey guys like
here's the thing I don't know what I'm
doing and I literally wrote that I was
like I'm a comedy writer I'm producing
this podcast for the first time so I'm
not trying to rip you off I just some a
human who makes mistakes and they
actually responded to it like really
well and of course they were immediately
because this is what happens whenever
you respond to someone's outrage they're
all like oh no we love you we're so
sorry that's exactly right no because if
you're contrite and you're like you're
like sorry I'm I you know I'm just I'm
just a person in the world like outraged
like you know that's that's a specific
thing right that's a sales thing a price
pricing mistake so that makes a little
bit more sense to engage with the fans
and say hey sorry but like you know for
however many thousands of people write
their comments on the internet there's
Millions more that never do yeah right
so you might be addressing
you know the smallest percentage of
outraged people who don't like your
mythical right they like we hate this
episode we think it was terrible or and
then you take time you almost like give
too much credit to their outrage and
then discredit all the other people who
weren't outraged sometimes I feel like
you know like engaging in the comments
or whatever
is like okay if you did a performance on
Broadway it's the Years 1972 right and
then you put on a costume went into the
lobby and heard every single person's
opinion about the play that is not
the gig the gig is you come out curtain
goes up you sing and dance say your
lines curtain goes down
you're done maybe you shake someone's
hand outside or sign an autograph but
the gig is not to then go person to
person tell me what you thought about
performance what did you think of the
performance are you happy oh you're
outraged oh my God let me explain you
why this is this way like it's a also if
you've never met what the process should
it is if you've ever sat in on a focus
group you know that if you ask people to
have an opinion sure and sometimes it's
not their natural opinion it's like that
they want to have a strong take imagine
what Sunny would have been if we poured
through focus groups trying to make the
show did you ever focus group no no no
no no no no no they never no I think
they they knew better than to try and do
that and FX is I mean I think
it I don't know do they do that with any
of their shows or do they just trust
their own tastes I mean I it wouldn't
surprise me with a bit of focus groups
yeah
I think there's a value to showing an
audience something right like you you're
cutting together a show or a movie and
you screen it from an audience but
that's for you that's true you can gauge
the reaction you feel the air go out of
the room first question you're like oh
maybe I need to tighten this up or like
but it's also like you know when you see
something that you made in front of an
audience even if you've been in the
editing room for a year editing that
thing the first time you see it in front
of an audience whether you're gauging
people's reactions or not
you're suddenly able to be a little bit
more objective about it I don't know
what that is I don't know because just
the awareness that other people are
watching it suddenly puts you in the
same place as the audience and you can
see you see things that you didn't
notice even though you've been in the
editing room for a year I think that's
an interesting phenomena like I've
always felt that anytime I've ever
watched something
I was painting a picture you know every
stroke you know how that tree got made
and you're looking at the tree for all
its parts right so you're like you're
like oh okay the trunk oh I I did that
little bit of sunlight on the trunk and
so that that's really making that seem
more three-dimensional and then you know
and then uh but you haven't like hung it
on a wall walked around the block and
then come in and looked at it with a
room full of people you know like and
then it's a different thing now you're
looking at the painting for the
experience of the painting itself as
opposed to the process of making it yeah
so there's like a yeah there's a weird
removal did you guys uh do a focus group
for uh for Mystic request Mr Quest no Mr
quiz I probably could have worked on
that title a little bit yeah yeah that
one maybe we actually got it yeah what
was my original hero Quest and then we
got to be clear 55 titles yeah and the
only one that would clear uh well there
were two that cleared Heroes Reign
spelled r-e-i-g-n
um which was a weird confusing title
um because
um and then Mythic Quest
um those are the only ones you tried
Mystic Quest too we tried everything
the curtain goes up and you have to sing
and dance curtain goes down and then
it's everyone else's issue after that
right like yeah but don't you find that
like that's fine with a live performance
but like I got into doing comedy because
I wanted to hear people laugh at stuff
that I made and wrote and I'm not a
performer so I didn't want it to be on
stage so it is like I find it really
hard to resist looking at Twitter and
Reddit and stuff about stuff that I've
made because I want to know that it made
somebody laugh like way back in the day
when I was living in New York and
writing for the onion I used to like if
I'd see somebody on the subway that was
reading the onion I would like stand
close to them just in case I might hear
them laugh at some of course yeah you're
doing it for the audience
yeah uh but probably what's worse than
seeing a bunch of bad comments about
something they did is seeing no comments
that's true no one talking about it yeah
like that's that's that's almost where
you're just like oh wow I just made a
thing and no one gave a [ __ ] it can go
either way you can either get too caught
up in everyone's negative comments or
too wrapped up in the positivity that
you then become you lose your own
objectivity about what you're doing yeah
that's the danger of it speaking of hard
uh criticisms to take in this episode
Dennis thinks he's a stallion and
there's a funny scene where Mac has to
break the news to him that um yeah he is
no longer a Beefcake yeah it's a very
it's a very funny performance of yours
you know because you you you really do
perform it like
you know when you feel bad for you
because you're not you're not aware yeah
but the fir yes exactly you feel bad for
him but the very first reaction is like
is also like oh no he doesn't know yeah
everybody in the room knows everybody
knows and he doesn't know because I
thought he knew I thought he knew he was
in Decline and now I'm gonna have to
tell him and you feel bad about it yeah
but it needs to be told it needs to be
said and in the clearest possible way
yeah so that you don't continue to
humiliate yourself correct in front of
all these wonderful people yeah yeah
I think it's very funny when your
horrible characters are trying to be
nice and kind to each other for like a
minute and break out of that I think
that's always like a good well like like
when Dee says I know you know I'm gonna
go do my own thing because I know you're
not gonna put me on this billboard you
know we're all agreeing with her yeah
you know we it's not that we think we're
being nice but we're like oh yeah no we
would no your app you're absolutely
right right you're absolutely right we
would never put you on that billboard
never ever yeah not you no oh my God we
don't even let her finish she starts by
saying I know what you guys are gonna
say and then we don't even let her
finish saying it we need to say it we
have to say it yeah yeah but it's all
done under the office of like you're
right you're right about everything that
you're thinking you're right so in a way
it's like we're we're like affirming
something but in the most negative
possible way
yeah which is uh I don't remember what
that volleyball was that I was throwing
at her face I mean it must have been
foam one of those no no it was like one
of those like little like uh like super
cheap rubber balls that you get at you
know I think it was foam because I think
if I threw a rubber ball had her face
that hard not even a cake ball I mean
one of those like talking about really
thinly thin layer of yeah layer of
rubber
I think foam would have hurt more
but I think I'm pretty sure they're good
that was like the comedy of it was it
bouncing so well that's what makes me
think that it was it was one of those
you know what I'm talking you know what
we're talking about like yeah you get
like a ball cheap like super thin almost
a balloon yeah yeah almost a balloon yes
that's only only slightly thicker than a
balloon really uh I think that's what it
was and they paid and they painted the
volleyball lines on there they drew or
drew them on or whatever and then and
then that same and then the volleyball
that you have in Philly is like it
totally it doesn't have the black
volleyball it's like a totally different
oh yeah ball different props people yeah
and then you did a stunt Glenn of
getting kicked in the nuts
um do you remember how they did that
yeah I just I don't remember so I
remember I was I thought like oh I'll
just wear a cup or whatever and then
we'll do a thing where you kick you know
that because that's kind of I remember
kick the inner thigh yeah make sure you
don't
but I actually wore some sort of a damn
don't remember but I do remember it was
like some sort of like a thing like that
that you know where my dick and balls
were here and this thing was here so
that you could literally kick me right
in the right spot and I would never
quite hit it would never quite reach my
my balls which were higher at the time
than they are
I couldn't do that now couldn't do that
now you'd have to yeah I'd have to wear
a real I'd have to Sag those stamps
yeah you could uh so yeah
um if you look at it though you can see
my pants are sagging like crazy because
I think I had them real low to
accommodate whatever that the ball trap
yeah the ball saver are your balls lower
than they're they're lower than they
used to be aren't they I have no idea I
I I've never measured the
proximity I've been keeping track of it
like you do with your kids hide on the
wall
I still got to see you tear away pants
in this and expose some tidy the same
tidy whities that I think you were
wearing when you were seducing um
a little too high wearing white socks
they're also pulled up real high and he
took a wide stance yeah I got myself
into a slightly wider stance good that
we knew that that would be funny right
that we weren't like yeah but he would
want to wear you know something that he
thought was sexier like that we were
just like he's just funny he doesn't
know yeah he doesn't know or he wasn't
he wasn't thinking about it or he thinks
he's so sexy that that doesn't even
matter yeah yeah that is what it is that
you know what that is what it is I loved
America's Next Top Model we both did you
and I watched it I watched it we watched
the entire first season of that show
like I would come over to your place
she's Fierce that they loved it it was
great it was amazing what'd you like
about it
yeah it was really funny Tyra Banks is
amazing I I just it was one of those
reality shows that I got into for this
like I wasn't into American Idol I never
really watched that um back in the day
and it was on around the same time so I
don't know it was just it was
fascinating a fascinating look into an
industry I didn't understand that's
exactly right it was fascinating it was
almost like wow I didn't know you know
but it was also fun to watch them try to
come up with different scenarios to put
the models in to make it a show it was
like okay and that's why we did the barn
that's why we did the Barnyard thing
because we were like that's what they
would do on America's Next Top Model
they'd be like you're uh space alien you
know they would just do this [ __ ] it was
like and try to make it seem like that's
something that would ever happen to you
like if you can't be a convincing
barnyard animal how you're never gonna
make it as a model and it's like what
what are you talking about like what's
that doing anything
it's just a competitive Moss ever had to
be a donkey probably not I'm not no you
guys watching reality shows now
or are you off reality show I I dip in
and out I mean there's a there's an
argument to be made that any any
professional sports program that you
watch is a reality show I mean it's the
same it's the same idea you're you're
watching a competition amongst people
and the only reason you really care is
the story behind it and they were just
really good at producing it so and me me
and my kids uh and Jill like as a family
we watch uh America's Got Talent okay so
I've realized that some there's some of
those big competition shows
that are uh they're a little bit you
don't feel like you're just kind of
sitting and just like that you know when
if you're watching it as a family it
feels like an actual event it feels like
something that you're doing together
like the survivalist ones
alone alone I love I haven't seen that
yet is that Netflix oh it's great it's
on Netflix
um and it I think it was like a Nat Geo
show and they basically dropped 10
people into like a really isolated
environment but they separate them all
and then it's a last man standing or
woman standing competition
um for who can survive in that place the
the longest and they only get to bring
like 10 items with them yeah it's really
good people are impressive like the the
structures they build are yeah snowflake
mountain did you watch it no but I saw
the commercial for it you did yeah and
where you had you you I'm sure you had
the same thought you were like ah I
might have to watch this and I did watch
it because I was in Ontario shooting the
movie so I had like more time to like
just watch things at times you know and
I watched that whole damn thing it was
basically I took a bunch of like really
rich like super entitled like young
20-somethings or like late teens early
20s and basically told them that they
were going to like a this awesome resort
to shoot like a reality show at this
Resort you know so they thought they
were all going to be like drinking and
partying and in a house put them through
hell and bickering and being in hot tubs
and [ __ ] instead they dropped them off
on a [ __ ] mountain top and they were
like
survive
[Laughter]
[Music]
this podcast is sponsored by betterhelp
online therapy I'm gonna toss something
out here it might be a bit controversial
but the past few years on planet Earth
have been a bit of a [ __ ] show right
right yes hunting so if you're like me
or literally any any human being who's
alive uh you you might well have some
you know some pent up feelings of about
the times we've been through and
and stuff out or say if you're
struggling with grief you know work
relationships stress or if you're having
trouble sleeping or meeting goals online
therapy might be for you now why online
therapy with better help as opposed to a
traditional therapist well better help
offers video phone and even live chat
sessions with a licensed professional
therapist so you can get help uh on your
time and and the privacy of wherever you
choose it's also more affordable than
traditional offline therapy and and
furthermore they have financial aid
available if you need it so you know
save some bucks save a trip to your
local therapist's office save an
uncomfortable stay in the waiting room
and try better help online today over 2
million people already have always sunny
podcast listeners and creeps get 10 off
their first month of online therapy at
betterhelp.com Sunny that's betterhelp
h-e-l-p.com slash sunny
[Music]
you uh uh might notice this in that
scene where Dennis arrives to take part
in the competition there is a man
standing near the um the sort of pole
and the bar and he
um and he has a couple lines and then he
he basically asks about how much money
they're getting paid then leaves and you
guys pointed out that that he recurs
that is the guy yeah that's the guy in
um PTSD PTSD ptsd12 yeah
so I as I recall at the time that we
cast that guy well he gave a great
audition so we were like oh we really
want this guy and I think we realized
we're like oh he's already been in an
episode he might have even said it I
think something makes me think maybe he
even said I've already done one or
something but but I think this makes
sense I think this makes sense and we
were like yeah it totally makes sense
like there's a million bars in Philly
yeah you know he had this one experience
where he tried to do a billboard thing
or whatever plenty of people have done
multiple episodes and some people have
done multiple characters yeah yeah but
in my mind he's playing the same he's
playing the same thing he just doesn't
remember that he's been and became a
stripper yeah yeah I was making money
from the stripping so that makes sense
it's consistent with his character yeah
exactly he shows up one minute Carter
McIntyre that's really good he's great
he's great in that little bit that he
does in this episode yeah and also
cameoing is one of your actual cameras
in this yes that's what we shot the uh
the actual series on the dvx100a the
camera that travels yeah
I think that was the [ __ ]
yeah so when I throw the volleyball in
Caitlyn's face uh when she's crazy Patty
the camera that we're filming her with
is the same exact cameras that we filmed
the show on and if they don't look like
giant expensive cameras it's because
they're not standard definition
4.34 colon three this is the aspect
ratio this was the last season that we
did
um in four three yeah season five we did
in 169 but still refused to go HD
I'm pointing at Charlie right now oh
yeah
season six we went we went HD although
we got probably the cheapest HD cameras
you could possibly get possibly because
we didn't actually I think that was uh
the thought was we don't want it to look
too drastically different but we know we
need to step into the modern era by
going HD because every TV was becoming
HD then so it was like wow this is going
to really really start to look different
and and even worse than it did before
pretty soon everyone's gonna have uh
Contraption on their television that
makes all television look awful so we
need to uh go ahead and like get into
that make sure that it can look as awful
as possible that's right that's right
I don't understand how people can't see
it they can't see it I was just 90 of
the population does not know that
they're watching Automotion plus I was
right a house in Rhode Island they
on their TV
couldn't you know there was no
remote for the TV there was a remote for
like uh just yeah like you can control
the whole system but you didn't have the
actual televisions
[ __ ] television yeah yeah it's
happened to me a couple times right to
not figure it out they must do focus
groups on that my guess is that because
otherwise why would Sony or whoever
building a TV focus groups uh for all
sorts of things I think when it comes to
like a story maybe not so much but like
yeah for whether or not television looks
like absolutely there's a reason why
Sony is refused they could very easily
just get rid of that feature because
they know everybody in Hollywood hates
it because the default settings
my point is that there they must be
using a data point to right to drive
that decision to say people actually
like this they want it on their
televisions people like soap operas and
that's what it makes everything look
like yeah that's right
that's right people must prefer it
otherwise I don't know why they would
make it as the default setting it
doesn't make any sense no the way I
don't think we do things just because
people prefer it it's it's like you
think there's something else going on
yeah I think it's it's too expensive for
them to now go figure out like a like
somebody came up with the technology
that people were like oh wow yeah when
you watch baseball game it is going to
look you know like like it is good for
them and on the field right where you
play a video game or something and then
someone was like oh but it's ruining
everything else and they're like yeah
but we already did it it's going to be
really expensive and time consuming to
figure out how to make other stuff look
good can't we just ruin everything so
people can watch the football game you
know like but they make a new thing a
brand new TV every you know six weeks
yeah but they don't break through with
technology every six weeks so like so I
mean making the TV smaller and thinner I
don't know it's so bad it's just so bad
really frustrating yeah just go into
your settings and turn off Automotion
plus I've got a TV in my house
uh where I have been through all the TV
that I got like a year ago yes and yes I
turned everything off and there's still
like a hint of it I have that too it's
still there I turned every [ __ ]
setting off on that television that
there is to turn off and I've used it
too much now to like I can't there's no
I can't there's no going back there's no
going back you'll have to go into the
one of the six or seven other rooms in
your house that has a TV well that's the
problem right because I'm like yeah I
can't which which room am I going to go
into where am I gonna where yeah which
which which room am I has the best TV
with the with the least that's what I'm
gonna spend you know we're going the
wrong direction where if you're on
airplane and you're watching on the
screen on the back of the seat that
screen it looks better than your TV at
home that's right yeah yeah like that's
uh We've [ __ ] up we've uh they [ __ ]
up they [ __ ] it up they've gone too
far they've gone too far they've ruined
television by the way I finally saw top
gun Maverick okay here we go I
yeah it's fan yes
fantastic yes
I loved it yes the whole I think the
whole movie I was like
just like from start to finish like the
second it starts and they and they put
that Top Gun song in they're like don't
gives you everything you need
now imagine uh a year from now uh you're
getting to watch that at home for the
first time and you're like huh what
these why'd they make it look like it's
all just like fake CGI and bad well they
did it they didn't is ruining it Sony
did Sony did Panasonic did so does that
mean you guys want me to stop publishing
the podcast with Automotion Plus on it
God damn it God damn it we might have we
might have beaten Joe Rogan if I hadn't
done that I think everyone's laptops
have it right so if someone is watching
this on their laptop yeah laptop's still
okay for now for now somebody's gonna do
it anyway I bet you there's some [ __ ]
PC company that's already done it I'm
like we got the ruining net we have the
ruining technology we just installed it
got it we got it we figured it we can
ruin movies on all your devices
we figured out how to ruin Movie
experience on all your devices yeah yeah
God bless huh